non et c'est comme les frites c'est quoi
ton re ou vous c'est nous les tuche
après d'arrêt d'après on est de retour à
bout c'est un voyou c'est exactement
c'est le moment de préparer noël en
famille moi ce qui se passe quand je
courais et je voudrais que ma soeur soit
il a aussi problème c'est son mari ce
coach henry en huit ça va vous êtes
chamailler là tous les deux là pour des
conneries il ya dix ans alors un marteau
tu as toujours travaillé je me régale
ses magazines magiquement une pizza chez
bata talibans jamais livrer une pizza au
fromage pas de pizza trois fromages deux
fois trois ça fait si ce problème là
rabibocher contrer l'ennemi est ce que
je disais déjà chez moi j'écoutais pas
aller voir lucide du père d'auray
et il a pu désigner jouer devant voire
des acquis maga zone marteau les gros
gagnants
les petits meurent vous êtes dans la
deuxième catégorie désolé j'ai une
proposition à vous faire voilà mon plan
racheter limacher et fabriquer des
jouets hambourg qu'est ce que tu fous là
marteau que des clous et fabrique un
jouet que nous n'avons pas vous pourriez
appeler l'inspection du travail l'avait
travaillé mais sais tu ce nom je ne
travaille pas je suis pas trop vous avez
déjà vu un patron qui travaillez-vous
[Musique]
il
c'est les écrans c'est quand même tu
connais tu connais quoi de quoi de quoi
ok j'y suis les efforts très drôle très
drôle très drôle
[Musique]